well everyone it's happening we're
coming up on the 20th anniversary of
peter jackson's adaptation of jrr
tolkien's the lord of the rings which
means it's the season for comprehensive
retrospectives on all things tolkien
jackson's adaptation is an undeniable
triumph both a lushly realized cohesive
vision of the text and a masterpiece of
savvy fandom marketing jackson made
extremely effective use of the internet
during production curating an official
fan club that lent the production a
sense of authority and consensus
whatever disagreement over adaptational
decisions the box set extended edition
dvd still stand as a masterpiece of
filmmaking and an undeniable set of bona
fides the display of a passion project
wrought on a scale that comes along once
in a lifetime with dozens of hours of
documentary combing over every minute
detail of the process and effort that
went into lovingly rendering the world
but before we all get swept away in that
fervor like nazgul in the river i wanted
to turn some attention towards ralph
bakshi's 1978 adaptation
[Music]
now i'm not setting out here to pit
these adaptations against each other but
comparison is unavoidable the jackson
trilogy looms large in culture
monolithic even not only is it the first
version of the story an entire
generation was exposed to it has
effectively mediated an agreed-upon
interpretation of the text by virtue of
its success as an adaptation by virtue
of looking and feeling right to the
audience's eye
whatever that nebulous word means in
this context bakshi's version is
undeniably far more fraught it is less
cohesive more reliant on an existing
familiarity with the source material
frustratingly paced and ultimately
incomplete it is often more accurate
more strictly faithful to the text but
just as often more hollow with details
that are true to the literal words on
the page while missing the underlying
point of those words but it's not
without its merits many of the
adaptation decisions are interesting or
excellent in their own right presenting
an interpretation of the text that is
wildly different but just as compelling
as jackson it is technologically decades
ahead of itself biting off far more than
it can chew in pursuit of technological
solutions that are now standard practice
this is a source of a lot of the film's
inconsistency but it's definitely a
fascinating inconsistency there is all
in all a lot more to it than just being
a weird early crack at a fantasy epic
and i think that's worth talking about
so let me tell you the story of a coked
out pervert from brooklyn and the movie
that he so desperately wanted to make
[Music]
first of all the lord of the rings the
book was not a runaway hit in the united
states while the component novels were
published in the u.s within six months
of their respective uk releases the
publisher houghton mifflin
underestimated how popular the books
would be the hobbit had been successful
but that was a children's book released
almost 20 years earlier a lot had
changed in america since 1937 and so the
initial print run of fellowship was only
1500 copies now if you only print 1500
copies it's hard to sell more than 1 500
copies so even though that print run did
sell out it's not a clear indicator of
the actual audience for the book and
doesn't really give you a good idea of
how many you should have printed
consequently it took years for sales to
ramp up as houghton mifflin opted to
trickle import copies from the uk
instead of issuing new print runs
somewhere in the early 1960s this
triggered a protectionist policy in u.s
copyright law that at the time mandated
a domestic manufacturing quota failing
to meet the quota the hobbit and the
lord of the rings fell into the public
domain in the united states where they
sat until a law was passed in 1994 to
restore the copyright to a number of
similarly odd cases where otherwise
still copyrighted foreign works had
fallen into public domain in the u.s as
a consequence of non-compliance with
formalities like manufacturing
requirements but point is even though
sales of the book had picked up
dramatically over the course of the 60s
particularly gaining traction with the
counterculture crowd who identified with
tolkien's pastoral environmentalism many
of these publications like the hundred
and fifty thousand copy ace books
paperback printing in 1965
weren't licensed and paid no royalties
back to tolkien this sparked a publicity
battle over the issue with tolkien
working with valentine books to produce
an authoritative authorized paperback
edition but is also when the books
finally surge in popularity a decade
after their initial publication by the
1970s the tolkien estate was actively
courting adaptations of jrr's work since
a licensed adaptation would actually pay
royalties and interest was finally there
in 1969 united artists purchased the
international film rights to lord of the
rings directly from tolkien and they
started trying to get a viable script
and interested director the idea of a
film version of lord of the rings had
already been floating around for years
with various speculative projects dating
back to the 50s but while the
counterculture crowd that had latched
onto the books was increasingly proving
to be a viable economic block it was
still not quite mainstream popular which
limited the possible budget of any
project united artists didn't have much
luck their attempts to get a full lord
of the rings project rolling largely
fell apart as the books developed a
reputation of being unfilmable not
because it was impossible but because
the budget would never be there to do
justice to the book's many grand
locations and fanciful sets
the story was simply too long to
realistically compress into a single
film but setting out to make multiple
films without assured success was folly
and surely audiences would revolt over
an incomplete story any attempt at the
time would be too compromised to satisfy
the books fans and too cheap looking to
satisfy anyone else then along comes an
animator named ralph bakshi born in
palestine but raised in brooklyn ralph
bakshi is you know
a bit of a character
everyone else is behind i'm not ahead
i'm doing what's right for an artist
he's doing what he believes in it's not
ahead of my time what i am is honest
what they are is dishonest he cut his
teeth as an animator in the 1950s and
60s at terry tunes at paramount working
in television shows like mighty mouse
deputy dog and spider-man before
pivoting to feature films in the 1970s
the lord of the rings was bakshi's fifth
feature film as a director and it is
notable as both a culmination of his
technical interests as an animator
utilizing mixed media as both a
cost-saving and aesthetic tool and the
ways in which it deviates from bakshi's
normal narrative style bakshi was raised
in the densely urban brooklyn
neighborhood of brownsville a
historically poor neighborhood that
while originally dominated by jewish
factory workers saw a heavy influx of
black residents through the 40s 50s and
60s this multi-racial urban milieu forms
the foundation of his early theatrical
work his first three films are all
considered part of the urban street film
genre but before that alright to put
this career into context we need to back
up to the 60s again the 60s were not
kind to theatrical animation in america
owing to shifts in the way that movies
were exhibited starting in the 50s
shorts became less financially viable
and so most of the money for animation
shifted to the rapidly expanding market
of television which hannah barbera and
warner brothers dominated theatrical
animation was largely the domain of walt
disney both the company and the man
walt had been an absolutely titanic
figure in the medium for decades but on
that front things were not great his
health was declining and the output of
the studio dropped precipitously leading
up to his death in 1966
while the studio had managed to put out
a new animated feature approximately
every 15 months on average over the
course of the 40s and 50s they only
managed to complete three films in the
60s 101 dalmatians the sword and the
stone and the jungle book the animation
studio relying mostly on re-issues of
their back catalog for the decade while
these films performed commercially well
the jungle book in particular being a
huge hit releasing in 1967 as walt
disney's final film they were not
particularly challenging
these were interwoven with reissues of
bambi pinocchio cinderella snow white
fantasia and peter pan and the follow-up
the first feature after walt's death is
1970s the aristocats which is just the
absolute pinnacle of disney's historical
reputation for anodyne garbage so this
is what feature animation looks like if
you're a 20 something in the 1970s this
is what you've grown up with there's
other stuff of course there's always
something on the periphery but
overwhelmingly the legacy of theatrical
animation is safe bright unscary trapped
decades in the past and slowly dying in
1968 ralph bakshi moving into his 30s
and frustrated with the stagnant status
quo of the industry broke away and
formed his own animation studio in
brooklyn initially the studio found work
on shows like rocket robin hood and
spider-man but bakshi had ambitions to
move into feature films he had a number
of projects already in mind including
the lord of the rings which he had
fallen in love with after the books
really broke out in the 60s while he
would spend years working on a half
dozen projects in parallel particularly
trying to get in good graces with united
artists who held the film rights for
lord of the rings the first film he was
able to secure full funding for was an
adaptation of comic artist robert crum's
underground hit fritz the cat released
in 1972 with an x-rating the film was
perverted juvenile rambling gratuitously
violent unfocused aggressively political
and a huge success
despite the rating limiting distribution
options the spectacle of a cartoon that
was the opposite of all things disney
drew in a worldwide audience to the tune
of 90 million dollars against a budget
of somewhere between 700 000 and 1.3
million following the success of fritz
the cat bakshi was able to fund and
distribute the animated
quasi-autobiography
pseudo-crime film heavy traffic released
in 1973 while not the astronomic success
of fritz heavy traffic made decent money
against its comparably slim budget and
is considered a box office success both
of these films did well with critics and
remain artistically relevant personally
i think heavy traffic is the better of
the two and certainly bakshi's best film
from the era though it does encapsulate
bakshi's overall sensibilities as a
creative there is a fixation on black
culture the complicated racial identity
of being jewish in america a deep and
total distrust of police disillusionment
with the results of the counterculture
movement and a keen sense of the ways
the structure of society is arranged to
maintain an underclass artistically
there is a fascination with the idea of
capturing reality photographs of real
locations are used as trace references
for background and fritz and many
backgrounds in heavy traffic are just
stylized photographs both films use some
documentary recording for secondary
dialogue captured by bakshi while
walking around harlem and brooklyn or
interviewing people he met on the
streets or in bars
the money is what's happening
see what i mean we're talking about it
all counts that is what's happening i'm
talking about as far as like if you want
to be revolutionary you get some bread
first and then you can talk trash whitey
blind us with religion
there's also a pervasive horniness as
it's rare to go an entire scene with a
woman without a breast popping out for
no reason the slapstick humor of terry
tunes is often extended into bloody
hyper violence and there is a
complicated relationship with queer
characters while bakshi's eye as a
director is certainly sympathetic to
drag queens trans women and gay men they
clearly form an integral part of the
real spaces and communities that he is
trying to simulate in his art
narratively they tend to be present just
long enough to be physically brutalized
as a condemnation of police and bigots
while these two films demonstrated that
adult-oriented animation could be
financially and critically successful
not much really changed in the wider
perception of animation these films were
still essentially novelties while there
was some attempt by others to capitalize
on the success of bakshi's films in
america this mostly took the form of
distributors quickly repackaging english
dubs of adult animation from japan and
europe back she would follow this up
with his most controversial film
coonskin an adaptation of the uncle
remus stories transplanting them from
the rural american self into a gangster
story in harlem while this movie
occupies something of a place alongside
contemporary blaxploitation films like
sweet sweet back's badass song dolomite
and shaft and has been praised for the
depth of the references in its
adaptation such as including details
from the african myths that predate
uncle ramus it also heavily utilizes
historical racist caricature and
minstrel imagery there's a lot of debate
about the artistic intent behind the
film whether or not the use of this
imagery is intended to shock and shame
the white institutions that created the
imagery in the first place how effective
it is at that and whether or not
protests of the film in 1975 were
justified
but reflecting on it 45 years later the
main thing that stands out to me is a
sort of fixation at play like back she
just wanted to also make a
blacksploitation film a genre that
sprang out of the kinds of neighborhoods
that he grew up in and out of a
community that he saw himself as a part
of and reception was far from universal
the congress of racial equality
protested it the naacp supported it as a
difficult satire and according to bakshi
the wu-tang clan love it it's a very
complicated intersection of politics and
influences that ultimately hinge on the
question of whether or not this was
bakshi's story to tell modern
commentators have compared it favorably
to childish gambinos this is america and
i guess at the end of the day the meat
of the film is that the cops and the
mafia suck
was not successful and did slow the
momentum on bakshi's career but it was
still a relatively inexpensive film and
the failure was not a fatal blow to his
career as a director during
post-production on [ __ ] skin bakshi came
up with a concept for hey good looking
another street film this time set in the
50s but one in which animated and
live-action characters would interact
warner brothers agreed to finance the
film in 1973 and the live-action footage
was shot largely improvisationally in
early 74. however the film would never
be completed as originally conceived as
the process of having live action and
animated characters interact proved to
be too labor intensive to complete on
the film's budget of 1.5 million a
rotoscoping rig was built at bakshi's
brooklyn studio to try and speed up the
animation process but a series of
conflicts between bakshi and warner
brothers led to the film's release date
being pushed back several times before
being shelved indefinitely while
heygoodlooking was trapped in
post-production hell bakshi would
release his first family-friendly
feature wizards which is also a
departure from his urban life focused
films into an explicit genre film family
friendly is a bit of a weird misnomer
here though as the film is still
deliberately aimed at adults rather than
an all ages crowd but it's also a lot
tamer with less sex gore and profanity
the film was moderately successful
enough to keep it from being considered
a flop which is somewhat impressive
given that the movie is quite bad aside
from some notable iconography and some
compelling backgrounds the flow of the
film suffers from all the disjointed
scene composition of bakshi's early
films while that works for heavy traffic
a film about powerless characters trying
to find their way in a disjointed world
it really works against a film that is
so plot heavy there's an entire movie's
worth of story dumped on the audience in
the prologue illuminating history
bearing on the everlasting struggle for
world supremacy first blast was set off
by five terrorists it was a big day in
montega delia felt a pull from the sky
the older fairy instantly knew that
these were not ordinary twins the day
will come my brother when i will return
and make this a planet where mutants
rule
politically the film is bizarre it is
clearly working through a lot of
opinions about the anti-war movement the
protagonists are mostly twee fairies
from a literal fantasy land of mushrooms
and rainbows who are mowed down by
machine gun wielding mutants hopped up
on nazi propaganda until the bearded
wizard ends the war by shooting skeleton
hitler but those opinions haven't been
worked enough to make them coherent or
interesting and the end result flips
rapidly between unbearably treacle and
deeply cynical it's not cohesive in
style the characters look like they're
from completely different films it's
horny in a way that's leerying and
uncomfortable rather than sexy and it's
pretty boring the most notable elements
of the film are all historical trivia
the film was being financed by fox and
back she found himself in budget
meetings with george lucas who was
working on star wars at the time and the
two became professional acquaintances
george asked ralph to change the working
title of war wizards to avoid conflict
with star wars and ralph agreed because
george let mark hamill take time off
from star wars to record a part in
wizards i'm sean leader of the knights
of stardust protectors of dolan king of
the mountain fairies it's also the first
film where bakshi really experimented
with mixing in stylized live-action
footage utilizing various rotoscoping
and xerox techniques to save budget on
animating large battle scenes the film
was moderately successful ralph's good
will towards george lucas came to an end
when star wars released three weeks
after wizards largely replaced it in
theaters parallel to the production of
most of these films bakshi pesters
united artists who have been stalling
out on all of their attempts at getting
a lord of the rings film rolling bakshi
says he pitched ua on an animated lord
of the rings in 72 and 73 but they
didn't bite then in 75 he convinces mike
medevoy to give him a chance and
medevoid agrees loosely to two or three
films plus something hobbit related
problem was united artists already had a
script written in 1970 by then tv writer
john borman who at this point in 1975
had just written and directed zardoz
the gun is good there was some conflict
over the script because
well it is absolutely buckwild there is
a galadriel frodo sex scene aragorn and
boromir kiss passionately with irwin's
blood on their lips the history of the
ring is presented as a rock opera at the
council of elrond and gimli is rebirthed
in mud to recall the ancient ancestral
password to moria bakshi convinced dan
melnick at mgm to buy out the project so
that they could throw the script out and
start over which they do so bakshi
starts over on the script with novice
screenwriter chris conkling but when dan
melnick gets ousted from mgm in 1976 the
new producer dick shepard doesn't seem
to know or care about the project at all
so back she gets in touch with saul
zance who had helped him finance fritz
back in 71 and convinces him to buy out
the project from mgm thus landing the
thing back at united artists
incidentally zance goes beyond this
buying out the entirety of tolkien's
film stage and merchandising rights
which starts a chain reaction that would
eventually lead decades later to the
troubled production that resulted in the
hobbit battle of five armies
so much
unsatisfied with conkling's work bakshi
and zanz sideline him and hire peter s
beagle author of the last unicorn to do
a rewrite which bakshi and zance are
mostly happy with and finally in 1976 a
theatrical lord of the rings film is
full steam ahead before the movie even
hits theaters though it has two
complications the first is obviously
bakshi's reputation and style is gandaff
going to whip his dick out and piss off
the bridge of kazad doom will pipeweed
be some dank bud who knows the second is
rankin bass an american production
company that mostly made seasonal
television specials by outsourcing
animation to japan rank and bass had
been working on an adaptation of the
hobbit as a tv special since 72 and it
was looking to broadcast by 77
additionally they had already
storyboarded a sequel to their hobbit
film utilizing large chunks of the
return of the king both of these would
conflict with any lord of the rings film
united artists produced particularly
once bakshi convinced them the film
could be done justice if it were
animated since audiences would assume
they were all related but since the
books were still public domain rank and
bass could do whatever they wanted at
least within the us and a lawsuit to
intervene succeeded only in securing a
broadcast agreement in canada
my precious
will it
tastes
delicious
bakshi's production even after settling
down at united artists was tumultuous
but mostly in a way that's probably
better described as indecisive the
script was overhauled several times
mostly because of arguments about how
much of the books should or could be
adapted into a single movie bakshi and
beagle ultimately pushed for two movies
the first encompassing fellowship and
two towers and intended for this film to
be subtitled part 1 but united artists
waffled on committing to a second film
they didn't outright say no in a way
that would have pushed the production to
commit everything to one film or make it
more conclusive but they also left the
fate of part 2 in the hazy realm of
let's wait and see what happens of
course as history has already borne out
the sequel was never produced and the
film ends up with a disorientingly quick
resolution where gandalf implies that
the battle of helm's deep is in fact the
deciding moment of victory end of story
released in 1978 reaction was lukewarm
but broadly positive and not terribly
harsh most of bakshi's idiosyncrasies as
a director are either absent or under
control
sort of
it's certainly the least juvenile no one
whips their dick out everyone's tits
stay inside their shirts there's no
random comedy skits and stirred it
haphazardly to pad runtime and the
adaptation is certainly faithful in the
sense that the vast majority of the
dialogue is copied directly from the
books but and this is probably its
biggest flaw it still exhibits bakshi's
inability to focus on the story at hand
jackson's films especially fellowship
are an illustrative comparison here
jackson's films are focused and cohesive
it's an adventure story about big events
and big emotions the unbreakable bond of
friendship forged in adversity the pain
of loss and the swelling moments of
triumph
[Music]
jackson gets how the characters and plot
interweave that it's explicitly a story
about how this big adventure changes the
characters and if you don't have both
then you don't have the hole
so here's the problem
bakshi just isn't very good at plot or
pacing he learned his craft working on
slapstick cartoons and his first three
films are effectively just a series of
vignettes heavy traffic is an urban
slice of life film and fritz the cat and
coonskin are both adapted from
explicitly episodic material this is not
strictly a criticism it works in heavy
traffic it's not a bad style there's
nothing wrong with vignette storytelling
it just needs the right material but
then you get wizards which is supposed
to be this really plot driven adventure
story heavy on world building and it's
just a meandering mess unimportant skits
drag on for minutes action scenes repeat
stock battle clips endlessly and
important moments resolve in seconds
well less extreme than wizards this is
unfortunately the main failing of lord
of the rings
back she was for most of the 70s both
extremely busy juggling multiple
productions simultaneously and also
allegedly on a lot of drugs it's just
not a state of mind that's really
conducive to making a film that
maintains a tight focus for two and a
half hours and it shows the film has a
lot of content to try and fit into its
run time and yet the flight at the ford
is an interminably long prog rock jam
session of frodo falling off a horse the
story is presented very literally lifted
straight from the novels but with little
wait for how it all connects together
this creates a notable problem when the
film transitions from fellowship into
two towers because the adaptation is so
faithful to the books that it feels like
you're at the end of the movie
but it just keeps going also the second
half of the film is pretty weak in
general
the sequences get really muddled a lot
of threads are dropped presumably to
have been picked up in part two and
there are more and more animation
shortcuts taken as the production ran up
against budget constraints on one hand
the sheer volume of roto done on the
battle of helm's deep is already immense
but on the other hand there's a lot of
shots like this where you can just
outright see that it's a guy wearing
rubber orc gloves
while otherwise the backgrounds in the
film range from gorgeously stylized
paintings to evocative abstract
non-landscapes for most of the battle of
helm's deep any background or distance
is filled with stock footage of clouds
regardless of camera angle on top of the
shortcuts bakshi is just generally not
very good at keeping track of the action
and geography of the fight scenes making
them really hard to follow and the muddy
high contrast artwork doesn't help then
at the end gandalf rides in and the
narrator implies that this battle
defeated sauron but also maybe stay
tuned for part two
the forces of darkness were driven
forever from the face of middle earth
by the valiant friends of frodo
as their gallant battle ended
so too ends the first great tale of
the lord of the rings
it's not a strong ending the film mixes
animation styles in a way that reads
like back she was constantly
experimenting on the fly and how a scene
ends up looking is dictated by what
seemed like a cool idea that week and
while this mixed media style is
interesting in its own way the
inconsistency of it contributes to a
sense that there wasn't a committed idea
everyone was working towards that the
ultimate creative vision was driven
mostly by momentary fascinations for the
lord of the rings bakshi utilized a
hodgepodge of animation formats
predominantly based on rotoscoping
modifying live action footage to various
degrees some of this involves using the
live action footage as a trace reference
the final product being a complete
replacement sometimes it's a paint over
effectively just augmenting the original
footage with details like eyes or fangs
and sometimes it's effectively just a
colorization of a xerox of the original
footage
and no that's not being snide an actual
process that was in use in the 60s 70s
and 80s involved photocopying line work
done on paper onto cellophane allowing
rougher pencil lines to be used without
inking an earlier version of this
technique is what gives 101 dalmatians
its distinctly ragged look if used on a
photograph however it crushes most of
the grayscale tones flattening the image
to solid blacks and whites
the second major technique used is
solarization which was recommended to
him by the film cinematographer timothy
galfes solarization more accurately
pseudo-solarization
is a tricky process where the black and
white film is partially developed then
instead of being sent through a process
called fixing the part of the
development that stabilizes the film so
it can be handled the image is
re-exposed to light and sent through the
entire development process a second time
this technique applied to photochemical
film is extremely difficult to control
largely relying on trial and error to
get desirable results but the successful
end product is a partially inverted
image with common artifact being a
strong border across high contrast
boundaries which can look kind of like
an inked outline bakshi felt this
stylization process was sufficiently
animation like that it would fit within
the movie and allowed them to use
footage of large-scale battles which
were ultimately faster and cheaper to
stage with actors in costumes than to
hand draw frame by frame even from a
reference all of these different
techniques are combined to various
degrees over the course of the movie
sometimes solarized footage is painted
over sometimes it's merely colorized
sometimes it's just played as is over a
colored background the extensive amount
of rotoscoping and repurposed footage
ultimately required the production to
shoot basically the entire film as live
action first with reference performers
stunt performers and the extensive
battle scenes so the two-year production
involved essentially making the entire
movie twice first in the live-action
shoot in madrid and second in the
animation there's a somewhat apocryphal
story in all of this in shooting the
footage they didn't really bother to
clear backgrounds of things like
telephone wires cars airplanes bicycles
and other obviously out of place
elements because it didn't really matter
it wasn't the finished film anyway
according to bakshi the spanish
developers who were handling the camera
negatives didn't understand that the
footage was a reference that would be
animated on top of thought that this was
instead incredibly sloppy filmmaking
feared that it would give madrid a bad
name and attempted to destroy the film
i'm repeating the story because it's
kinda cute but it's also a bit too weird
and sensational and the only source is
bakshi himself who is
let's just say
prone to exaggeration like he'll say
they had 600 animators working on lord
of the rings when reality it was more
like 50. i was over spain shooting major
live-action footage at 3 000 people in
the studio back in new york animating
i'm fielding 500 calls a day from the
promised studio i'm shooting an entire
live action movie and i'm trying to eat
dinner with zentz at night who wants to
be talked to or this bit from a 2006
interview with underground online i had
the x rating on my films and that should
have been enough to protect me it was
all a misunderstanding of me being too
far ahead of the curve now they do as
much on the simpsons as i got an x
rating for fritz the cat and like
no
no ralph no they don't no they don't
what do you think happens on the
simpsons i am very curious what ralph
bakshi thinks happens on the simpsons on
the whole the film is a mixed bag
there's a lot of jank but what works
what does it get right
a lot actually
whoa some ganji
your legs are too short so use your head
the vocal performances in particular are
generally good often great the voice
actors do well with tolkien's words with
an interpretation that is both distinct
and appropriate one thing that's often
cited as a standout though is john
hurt's performance as aragorn and for
good reason it's fantastic it matters we
still have a long road and much to do
why we've no hope without gandalf you
know that aragorn then we must do
without hope there is always vengeance
gruff yet warm there's a lot to love
about this performance john hurt was a
great actor and he absolutely has a
world weary charisma that really works
here it's fantastic i love it and it
meshes well with bakshi's naturalistic
filmmaking sensibilities this version of
the characters that are not so much the
protagonists of a fantasy epic but just
some dudes trying to solve a problem we
have no choice at all we might go by way
of the gap of rohan that would take the
ring too close to isengard and man we
dare not risk it yet you would risk the
minds of maurya while bakshi is bad at
pacing in action he's got a good sense
for the interplay between characters and
the film's best moments come in snippets
from these interactions the dynamics of
conflict and dialogue and the small
physical actions that punctuate those
moments
scenes like boromir's death hold
sufficient dramatic weight the reference
acting animation and vocal performances
all come together and really work in a
way that shows off the film at its
strongest just the clink and clank of
equipment the subtle atmospheric wind
and a mature tenderness as the three pay
respects to a fallen comrade and there's
little moments just great touches of
detail like sam and frodo paddling in
opposite directions as they debate the
next course of action where the rhythm
of it is spot on a fantastic little
flare that communicates the emotion that
underlies the dialogue it's a keen
physical detail that a lazier production
would miss the twitchy feral movements
of the black riders is a weird creative
decision but i think it works it's
unsettling and menacing in an unusual
way though it does get a little odd when
the nazgul simply stop behaving like
this after the prancing pony again
consistency is a problem there's also
small adaptational decisions lord of the
rings is so big and sprawling that
basically any cinematic adaptation will
have to pick and choose what it includes
and what it doesn't for as comprehensive
as the jackson films are there's a lot
they had to leave behind
like this little moment after gandalf
opens the door to moria so all you had
to do was say friend
and then
those were happier time
it's a great little touch to include
because the whole joke of the door to
moria for the reader is that they're
overthinking the problem that the
troubles facing the fellowship the rise
of sauron in the east has created a
culture of fear a culture of security
and paranoia that leads gandaff to
assume the answer is more complicated
than it really is it's a melancholic
point about how the people of middle
earth have grown apart distrustful and
isolated to the point that even being
asked to say friend feels like a trick
it's a good detail to include
bakshi's film is basically the only
adaptation to include frodo's defiance
of the ring wraiths at the ford by all
that shire you shall have neither the
ring
nor me i also really like the
introduction presented as a shadow play
it's cheap and poorly acted and looks
like community theater but that's what i
find endearing about it like it could
just as well be an in-universe
performance of myth you've got actors
who are clearly trying to avoid hurting
each other with their prop swords and
are miming slow motion instead of
actually shooting the footage in slow
motion and it's clearly taking place on
a stage but the fact that it's so
evidently low budget i don't know
i find it charming now unfortunately for
all the things that i do enjoy about
this movie all the things that i think
work or are at least admirable for their
ambition there's a lot that doesn't
either failing entirely or just not
quite coming together into a cohesive
whole like for example the balrog
alright so a bit of a side track with
the balrog here one of the biggest
running arguments in tolkien scholarship
is this does the balrog actually have
wings or does it merely have a form that
is evocative of wings or does it have
neither wings nor a form evocative of
wings but an incorporeal aura of
darkness that projects the impression of
wings without being a component part of
the substance or form of the balrog's
essential self relevant passages from
the book are in the fellowship of the
ring where first tolkien writes about
the balrog the shadow about it reached
out like two vast wings and a couple
paragraphs later it stepped forward onto
the bridge and suddenly it drew itself
up to a great height and its wings were
spread from wall to wall this apparent
conflict between a stylistic description
and a literal description has formed the
foundation of a half-century long debate
over the intended physical properties of
a mythological demon as of june 2021 the
tolkien society fact still has as the
top entry do balrogs have wings can they
fly which they summarize with that's up
to each individual reader to decide
quora the spiritual successor to yahoo
answers has multiple threads on the
subject back she perhaps unknowingly
stepped right in this when he gave the
balrog big ol bat wings with a balrog
that's definitely reminiscent of the
hilda brandt brothers balrog from the
1977 tolkien art calendar the 1987
calendar featured a wingless balrog
painted by tolkien scholar ted naismith
john howe's 1996 painting gandalf falls
with the ball rug features a distinctly
bat-winged demon peter jackson threaded
the needle with a balrog that is as much
a smoke monster as it is physical though
it still definitely has wings video
games also alternate between wings and
no wings tolkien hack david days a
tolkien bestiary indicates no wings
while robert foster's authoritate of the
complete guide to middle earth is mum on
the subject the online encyclopedia of
arda dating back to 1997 spends four
fifths of his word count for the entry
on balrog summarizing both the pro and
anti-wing arguments though ultimately
airs on the side of no wings without
taking a definitive stance the start of
this argument naturally just spurs
further arguments the balrog were
created with intent by melchor therefore
vestigial wings would be illogical and
if the balrog had wings then surely it
wouldn't just plummet when the bridge
collapses which leads to arguments about
the nature of wings themselves since
after all even if it has wings it's not
a helicopter or a hummingbird and
probably couldn't just hover penguins
chickens and emu all have wings but they
would plummet even flighted birds like
condor and albatross can't just take off
from a standstill but this argument also
neglects to consider that both melchor
and the balrog were created with intent
by one honorable mr sir joking rolkin
roll king tolkien and wings are both rad
badass functional or not and anyway if
balrog have wings why couldn't they just
fly the ring into mordor
now the wings are not something that
particularly bothers me the hildebrand
painting is actually my earliest memory
of tolkien period as it's the cover of
the book art of the brothers hildebrand
and we had a copy kicking around the
house when i was a kid so this is
already a formative vision of the scene
for me clearly the actual fact of wings
is secondary to the narrative
functionality of the evocative image of
gandav as a point of light standing off
against an enveloping darkness the
actual problems with the balrog here in
bakshi's version aren't wings in and of
themselves but that the design just
doesn't come together and most
importantly is really poorly animated
now back she is an animator is not
particularly good at momentum motion and
momentum are core elements of animation
and it's something that bakshi has
always struggled with part of his
experimentation with rotoscoping was
tied to this it's a cost-saving measure
but also it means that the momentum
problem solves itself you have real
footage to work from the momentum is
already real it's done for you boom of
course animated momentum and real
momentum aren't the same thing and your
rotoscope is only going to look as good
as your source footage which is going to
be really hard to get right if you don't
have a 12 foot tall balrog to shoot some
reference footage of this is a moment
where the realism of rotoscoping is
absolutely undermining the final product
because we are unfortunately seeing
through to the underlying reality of a
man in a costume trying to mime being
really big by just moving slowly it's
not dynamic it's not threatening and it
comes off as unfortunately goofy this is
a running thing through the film most of
the action scenes lack a sense of weight
to their movement the actors are just
lightly swinging their prop swords at
each other pulling their punches because
you know it's just a reference but since
the reference is being traced frame by
frame that performance carries through
to the final animation sometimes the
rotoscope inherits a really effective
sense of weight and sometimes it ends up
looking cheap and fake this also leaves
behind a number of strange artifacts in
how shots are framed they're few and far
between but there's the occasional shot
where the framing is oddly tight where
characters drift out of frame in a way
that's highly unusual for animation
where the positioning of characters is
normally extremely deliberate the
pitfall of a rotoscoped film is that the
final results depend heavily on your
references the reference performers
aren't simply providing something to
help the animators get the right idea
their performance
is the performance and there's a
definite inconsistency here and that's
really the word of the day isn't it
the biggest failings of bakshi's lord of
the rings are matters of inconsistency
sometimes the reference actors are
giving it their all and sometimes
they're just loosely miming the actions
sometimes footage is shot in slow motion
and other times the actors just swing
their swords slowly scenes change style
and grain and texture on the fly and
characters are animated in multiple
different styles across the film as a
whole heck sometimes characters switch
techniques multiple times within the
span of a few seconds as with aragorn
running down this hallway there's also a
thing that happens a few times where the
scenes were too complicated to fully
animate like mary and pippen fighting
the orcs before their capture but the
underlying footage is in really bad
shape super high contrast super
underexposed super grainy and the whole
image just turns into an indecipherable
blob a much commented on quirk of the
movie is that a lot of the characters
wave their hands around really aimlessly
this is going to come down to a
direction issue as it's a very community
theater kind of quirk of acting with
untrained actors over using their hands
the nazgul and orcs being mostly paint
over work with much of the actual
costume still visible
works but is undercut by the fact that
the fellowship too
are often animated as paint overs with
their live-action counterparts being
extremely visible even the full
replacement trace-overs aren't without
their own oddities as the style is so
chaotic with line work that squiggles a
lot between frames that it's extremely
intrusive when characters stop moving
entirely becoming unnaturally still for
a few frames between actions that's a
limitation of budget yes and i don't
begrudge the animators for saving those
frames but the style very much
accentuates the effect and calls
attention to it tree beard is pretty
much the only character in the film
that's entirely animated from scratch
which places him out of place at the
other extreme end of the spectrum being
very fluid and morphy traditionally
cartoonish looking more like an outcast
from an atkinson production like the
raccoons than the comparably heavy
animation of the rest of the film and
while that heavier animation generally
looks really neat the increased fidelity
will again work against the film as any
time the lip sync is off it feels really
off without i to start
there's also an issue with the dialogue
that well
descriptively the dialogue in a lot of
places is stilted and the recording is
thin the micro pacing of dialogue that
makes it feel natural that makes it flow
it's not always there and a lot of
unspoken vocalizations are missing which
can make conversations drag and feel
unnatural i'll give it to you gandalf
you're wise and powerful
what will you not no
do not tempt me
this is a result of the production
process there's two factors here for i
guess budgetary reasons they apparently
didn't have a multi-track recorder and
also the voice actors are ultimately
having their performance superimposed on
the performance of the live action
actors which is substantially different
from other methods of animation where
either the animators work from the
actor's performance where the actor
matches the performance created by the
animators and so while the production
opted to do the recording sessions with
the cast as a group according to anthony
daniels the actors were required to
leave a long two-second pause between
each other's lines so that the editors
could try and line the two performances
up i mean i can see the logic there like
you assume you've got this process that
affords you a lot of freedom you don't
need to wait for one part to be done so
that the other half can match it you can
just do both halves whenever it's
convenient and then merge them later
but you know
it's the details that get lost in that
process
on the whole the film's pacing is just
really off some sequences like the
flight to the ford mentioned before go
on at seemingly and in terminal length
while the entire second half of the film
is incredibly rushed even one-off
moments will end up bizarrely truncated
like the smoke trailing out of moria
behind the fellowship which flashes on
screen so briefly i wasn't sure if i had
bumped the remote and skipped a scene
mary and pippin vanished from the film
entirely after meeting treebeard a
casualty of the unproduced sequel but
regardless of the intent their exit is
undeniably sudden likewise sam and frodo
meet gollum set off towards the dead
marches and are never seen or mentioned
again one particular oddity is that
saruman is alternately called either
saruman or aruman i must go south now to
consult with the wizard arrow man
i have come for your age sarah the white
in trouble times this bizarre
inconsistency is a result of saul's ants
insistence that the names of the
antagonists sauron and saruman sounded
too alike which is fair enough as an
adaptation change but then during fairly
routine rewrites mid-production beagle
began swapping the names back to saruman
[Music]
if there is something you can say is
missing from bakshi's middle earth it
would be middle-earth itself this is
perhaps where the comparison between
bakshi and jackson is the starkest while
much of this is an argument of
adaptational preference which lines and
details were included which phrases and
character traits were stressed one area
where the older film is undeniably
weaker is in the presence of the world
and this is a meaningful absence
place is critical to the story of lord
of the rings because lord of the rings
is as much a story about violence
against the land itself as it is about
violence against the people who live on
it and while bakshi's artists are able
to visualize many iconic locations both
the fantastic and the quaint just as
often the background dissolves away into
abstraction into nowhere in particular
though there is an isolated artistry to
these compositions as a storytelling
mechanism as an expression of the text
they just don't compete with jackson's
camera turn towards the beauty of new
zealand this gaze importantly retains
the essence of the message the world is
good the world is beautiful the world is
worth saving and not just the so-called
important parts
tolkien's notoriously florid
descriptions are just as reverent of
grassland and marsh as they are of
forest and mountain
this is the biggest misstep of the old
adaptation the vision of middle earth
not just as a land under assault from a
malevolent spirit seeking power but a
land besieged by the smog and
consumption and poisonous runoff of
industry ultimately the biggest flaw of
the film is that it's kind of boring not
uninteresting but all these issues add
up to long stretches of the film that
just aren't particularly noteworthy
there is at least in my opinion very
little after the death of boromir that's
really worth it and given that his
funeral is 85 minutes into the movie not
only is it a clear demarcation point
between two parts of the story it's
already a decent feature length so
if you kind of check out there i don't
really blame you there's also a deeper
issue that kind of cuts two ways and
it's that the film relies a lot on
understanding the source material now i
don't think this is a conscious reliance
i do think that bakshi and conkling and
beagle tried to create a telling of the
story that's self-contained but there's
enough holes enough things that are
breezed past that there's definitely the
sense that things are missing the keen
awareness that this is an abridgement of
a much larger book and so bits are
included for the sake of being
comprehensive rather than because they
make the best version of the story for
the medium i said this cuts two ways and
that's because while this can make for
an unsatisfying viewing on its own it
can also potentially make for a
satisfying companion to the novel where
the viewer's own knowledge of the text
is able to fill the gaps and their
imagination is able to do the heavy
lifting of fleshing it all out using the
movie as an aide to their own internal
visualization and realization of the
story part of the trouble in researching
the film is that based on bakshi's own
recollections of the film it's not even
entirely clear when they decided to
animate the film or if the whole film
was meant to be conventionally animated
with only a bit of rotoscoping but then
they decided to rotoscope nearly the
entire thing or if at one point they
were even considering cutting the
animation entirely and just making a
live action film these were apparently
decisions that were made more or less on
the fly in 1976 a reflection of the
problems plaguing the still unfinished
hey good-looking i don't want to say
that this is a film made by filmmakers
who didn't care who didn't
get the source material it is a film
that's lovingly made it is a film that's
made by creatives who cared the script
is clearly intimately familiar with the
source material but it also seems like a
film that was made by creatives who were
very distracted who didn't have a strong
vision and were focused principally on
working quickly and making whatever
compromises were needed
just to get things done and to be clear
that's not a moral failing it's not a
sin to be more concerned with getting
the film done getting it in front of
audiences than picking fights with the
studio they turned around a two and a
half hour animated film in two years
that's insane it's amazing that the
whole thing didn't entirely
self-destruct the final result is not
only reasonably watchable but often
interesting and occasionally brilliant
that's impressive
so the movie comes out with the title
the lord of the rings no part one
subtitle united artists felt that no one
would want to pay to see half a story of
course that seems ridiculous today what
with film being so thoroughly dominated
by serial franchises but in 1978 the
concern was still sensible the two-part
film didn't really exist yet and even
franchises were sparse and more along
the lines of james bond a loosely
connected episodic rather than a single
cohesive story with meaningful
continuity but still a to be continued
would not have seriously shocked
audiences well bakshi had done some
press where he was able to talk about
how they'll hopefully get to make the
rest of the story with part two the
media landscape was entirely different
in 1978 there isn't a massive ecosystem
of entertainment news there's no
widespread internet there's no fan blogs
hanging off every detail of production
so the general audience impression going
in is that this is the whole thing fans
of the book are of course caught off
guard by the ending the story just
stopping after the battle of helm's deep
and they're not super happy about that
but on the whole audiences are
pretty receptive and the film does well
critics are lukewarm but consensus is
ultimately positive roger ebert's bottom
line summary is i think right on the
money quote in sum bakshi has succeeded
better at bringing tolkien's characters
to life than it bringing his story to
fruition and that's kind of where things
have stayed critical reevaluation hasn't
really changed over the decades since
it's flawed mostly boring but not
entirely devoid of charm it's quieter
and stiffer than jackson's
high-intensity action adventure but
that's not wholly inappropriate as
tolkien's books are themselves so very
often quiet and stiff the film was
successful it turned a reasonable profit
but it wasn't a runaway success back she
was feeling burnt out on working on
someone else's story and leadership
changes at united artists in 1978 proved
to be enough of an interruption to the
momentum of the project that attempts to
get part two moving just fizzled out
bakshi would continue to use rotoscoped
animation for three of his next four
films though audience interest waned as
the style grew increasingly dated
compared to the lush and intricate
animation of its big budget
contemporaries and as back she seemingly
ran out of energy and ideas
hey good looking was eventually released
in 1982 in a totally overhauled format
the film having been essentially remade
as a totally animated feature over the
course of seven years financed by bakshi
himself though little of the rotoscoping
remained it is for the most part just a
worse version of heavy traffic lacking
the incendiary politics and righteous
anger that gives that film its bite i
don't know maybe it was just bakshi
getting older maybe you just couldn't
sell an anti-cop movie in reagan's
america he eventually retired from
feature films after the flop of cool
world in 1992 a film that was ironically
not nearly as crass as audiences had
hoped but as a pure quirk of coincidence
the animated legacy of the lord of the
rings isn't entirely incomplete because
rank and bass leveraging the public
domain status of the books aired the
sequel to their hobbit adaptation in
1980 and it just so happens to more or
less pick up shortly after bakshi's film
ends the specifics here are disputed
since the rank and bass return of the
king had been storyboarded years earlier
but it also didn't really start serious
production until 78 so while the film
wasn't intended to capitalize on the
cancellation of bakshi's second film it
still did mostly bad in an annoying way
and very cheaply made this tv movie is
largely unmemorable save for the
absolute banger where there's a whip
there's a way
of course then a little over 20 years
later peter jackson that guy who makes
perverted puppet movies would finally
get to make a no-holds-barred adaptation
of the lord of the rings and
it's really good come on mr frodo
i can't carry it for you
but i can't carry you ultimately the
legacy of bakshi's film is in technology
techniques that were odd and unique are
today routine he didn't invent any of
them strictly speaking the underpinning
technology was already decades old but
the haphazard experimental ambitious way
that they're applied the mix of success
and failure is ahead of its time
pre-saging the ways that filmmaking was
changing and would continue to change
this isn't to say that bakshi and his
animators changed the arc of history but
rather they saw what was inevitable
about the way that these technologies
would be applied and bit off far more
than they could chew decades before the
tech was actually ready back she
understood that the greatest limitation
of realizing the world of tolkien was
the world itself and he solved this
problem by cutting out photographs of
actors maybe painting on them a little
and placing them into animated
environments and that right there
describes
basically every marvel movie for 20
years now it's been routine for actors
to work against worlds that they can't
see that are created out of whole cloth
by animators the modern look of films is
defined by actors on set wearing some
combination of costume that's limiting
or suggestive of the final look before
artists go in afterwards and paint the
rest of the costume on taking a physical
performance and duplicating it with an
emulated simulacrum once the odd
fixation of a few weirdos from brooklyn
is now ordinary
in a weird way bakshi's lord of the
rings is a 21st century blockbuster made
with 1970s technology and in the end he
would ultimately be vindicated the
argument that animation could be more
mature could be dramatic could be adult
could be a perfect medium for a story
like the lord of the rings
was absolutely true and bakshi's work
wouldn't be relegated to mere novelty
status despite the waning attendance to
his own films his work in the 70s more
or less set the tone for feature
animation in the 80s which was dominated
by the dark often somber films of don
bluth because everything is connected
rank and bass worked with peter beagle
and turned his book the last unicorn
into a haunting and mature film in 1982.
even disney on the verge of bankruptcy
would try to play to the trend with
their own adaptation of a mid-century
fantasy epic with the notorious flop the
black cauldron then of course the
simpsons would begin airing in 1989 in
1993 mtv began a late night block of
adult animation that ran the whole gamut
from crass to cerebral and over the
course of the 80s and 90s anime would go
from being a niche import to a staple
pillar of modern animation
so that's the story of bakshi in the
ring i think what i find compelling
about his lord of the rings is a summary
of what i find compelling about the man
himself and his career as a whole one
that is deeply flawed but undeniably
bold and
occasionally brilliant
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you